a lone explorer
on a mission to reveal the grandeur of
Saturn its rings and moons
[Music]
after 20 years in space NASA's Cassini
spacecraft is running out of fuel and so
to protect moons of Saturn that could
have conditions suitable for life
a spectacular end has been planned for
this long-lived traveller from Earth
[Music]
we have planted the tower in 2004
following a seven-year journey through
the solar system
Cassini arrived at Saturn burn habitat
under 20 position light up the Rockets
the spacecraft carried a passenger the
European Huygens probe the first
human-made object to land on a world in
the distant outer solar system for over
a decade Cassini has shared the wonders
of Saturn and its family of icy moons
taking us to astounding worlds where
methane rivers run to a methane see
where Jets of ice and gas are blasting
material into space from a liquid water
ocean that might Harbor the ingredients
for life
and Saturn a giant world ruled by raging
storms and delicate harmonies of gravity
now Cassini has one last daring
assignment Cassini's grand finale is a
brand new adventure 22 dives through the
space between Saturn and its rings as it
repeatedly Braves this unexplored region
Cassini seeks new insights about the
origins of the rings and the nature of
the planets interior closer to Saturn
than ever before
[Music]
on the final orbit Cassini will plunge
into Saturn fighting to keep its antenna
pointed at earth as it transmits its
farewell
[Music]
in the skies of Saturn
the journey ends
[Music]
as Cassini becomes part of the planet
itself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]